abone ol
Ne borcu Opel zümran Ömür çivi prized
attı rasyonalizasyon Ben sizlere Kars'ın
boğatepe Köyü nün kucak dolusu selamlar
getirdin
[Müzik]
ama ben evliyim 3 çocuk annesiyim bir
tane gelinin Bir de çok kıymetli bir
torunum var bari ki tane oğlum
Üniversitesi mezunu ve bir lisede okuyor
kartın boğatepe köyü nde yaşıyorum ve
sizlere var TP köyündeki insanların
hayat hikayesini Anlatmaya çalışacağım
Biz Kadınlar köyde evden ahıra ahırdan
eve giden sadece yemeğini yapan ve
çocuğunu büyüten aileler di ve
televizyondaki o güzel dizilere Özenen
köyden Biz de gitmek isteyen kadınlar
artık ama bizim köyümüzde kötü bir şey
yaşandı mm yılında köyümüzde bir kaza
oldu köyümüzde 22 kişiyi kaybettik Biz
22 kişi kaybolunca köyümüzde ağıtla
mı geldi ve köyümüzde göç vermeye
başlamıştık 25 ayda Göç Göç Oldu
köyümüzden gözlük gittiler köyümüzde
artık üretim durmuştu ve kadınlar
evlerinden çıkmaya başlamıştı hiçbir
etkinliğimiz olmaya başlamıştı köyümüz
Çünkü artık yok olmaya başlamıştı bir
gün oturduk düşündük İlhan koçulu abimiz
eşim Kazım Ömür ve ben köyümüz için ne
yapabiliriz ki tekrar hayata geri
kazandıralım köyümüzü dedik ve köyümüzü
geri kazandırabilmek için boğatepe çevre
ve yaşam Derneğini kurduk bu ATP çevre
ve Yaşam Derneği bize bir nefes oldu ve
hayata belki de geri dönmem izi sağladı
şöyle bu ATP çevre ve yaşam Derneği'ni
kurduk köyümüzde 650 tür bitki
çeşitliliği var Biz Bu 650 tür bitki
çeşitliliğine
bu arkasındaydık ve uzman hekimler
getirdik uzman hekimler bize doğru
toplamayı doğru kurutma Öğrettiler nasıl
günümüzde Şifalı bitkileri
kullanacağımız öğrendik koruyacağım
aşkla kullanmamız gerektiğini ve
bağışıklık sistemimiz güçlü olursa
hastalıklara yakalanma yapacağımızı
söylediler gelen Uzmanlar biz köyümüzde
farklı bir köyümüz var 2400 rakamlı
köyümüzde çiftçilik yapıyoruz üreticimiz
köyümüz üretim yapıyoruz ve doğadan
biçtiğimiz ürünleri hayvanlarımıza
getirerek hem hayvanlarımız sağlıklı
hayvanlarımız dan aldığımız ürünü de
sağlıklı olmasını sağlıyoruz
bu köyümüzdeki peynirlerimiz bizim için
önemliydi ve köyümüzü ve Kars bölgesinde
coğrafi işaretleme yaptırdık ki bizim
ürünlerimizin Kars'a ait olduğu bilirsin
Bu peynir çeşitliliğimiz yapıyoruz ama
bizim bir peynirlerimiz de ki özellik
biyografik bakterilerin çok oluşu şifalı
oluşu ve Diyoruz ki şifamız gıdanız
gıdanın şifamız olsun diyoruz yiyen
kişilere
ama biz eğitimler aldık eğitimler
doğrultusunda hep hareket etti Hiç
eğitim dışına çıkmadık çünkü hem Tıpkı
bitkilerde hem yapmış olduğumuz
ürünlerin kaliteli düzgün insan
sağlığına faydalı olsun istediğimiz için
eğitimler sürecinde hep hocalarımızdan
dinleyerek ve öğrenerek takip ettik
bu eğitimlerimizi aldık ama biz bir
yılda Fransızca kurs gördük dil öğrendik
bir dil bir insan dedik Biz niye
öğrenmeli belki kırsalda olabiliriz ama
biz de öğrenelim dedik ve Fransa'dan
tema diye bir dernekle kardeşlerdeki
olduk kardeşlerine yılda Siz dil öğrenin
bir size misafirler gönderelim dedi
gelen Fransız Misafirlerimiz evlerimiz
ağırladık bir kültür paylaşım olsun ve
çocuklarımız gelen kişilerden hem Onlar
bizden bir şeyler öğren Sen hem de biz
onlardan Belki de bir şeyler öğrenip
hayatımıza katacağınızı düşünerek
Fransızca kursu aldık köy kadınlar
olarak Fransızca öğrenmiş olduk ah
O bizim köyümüz yüksek rakımlı bir köy
2400 rakımda yaşıyoruz biz soğuk iklime
sahip bir Köyü O yüzden köyümüzde ağaç
bile yetişmez soğuk olduğu için biz
küçük nasıl beslendiğimiz beslenme
uzmanlarından öğrendik Doğru
beslenmektedir Onu öğrendik ve küçük
küçük Bahçeler hazırlamaya başladık
sebze yetiştiriciliğine başladı köyler
köyümüzde sebze yetiştiriyoruz etin
yanında da sebzenin tüketilmesi
gerektiğini öğrendik ve sebze
yetiştiriciliğine başladı ı Bazen küçük
Sebzecilik büyük sebzelik çiziklere
dönüştü Çünkü artık sadece Kendimiz için
değil yanımızda komşunu da üretime
başlanmasını istedi Böylelikle de
sebzeciliği mizi de başlatmış olduk
Sen demin dediğim gibi köyümüz 2400
rakımlı bir köy Ey soğuk bir köydür her
zaman ya da soğuktur kişide soğuktur ve
sabahleyin Bir saat beşte kalkıp
yemeklerimizi sağlamamız lazım
hayvanlarımızın Bakımlı sağlamamız lazım
Biz -45 dereceyi görüyoruz O yüzden
eklem ağrılarınızın çok olduğu görülür
ve eklem ağrılarınız için ne yapabiliriz
diye araştırma yaptık araştırmalarımız
ın sonucunda yoga'nın çok iyi geldiğini
öğrendik ve yoga kursu hocalarımız geldi
köyümüzde bize yoga Öğrettiler eklemler
nasıl çalışır bir ya da Ayakların nasıl
çalışması gerektiğini çakraları
çalıştırdık bazen işimize başlamadan
önce de Home yapıp öyle başlıyoruz ki
konsantre olalım bizim köy
bu kaybolmaya yüz tutmuş bir tohum
çeşitliliğimiz vardı kavılca buğdayı
diye kabaca buğday ımızı tekrar geri
sofralarımıza koymaya başladık ve
faydalarını dedelerimizin gördüğü için
Bizde faydalanalım dedik 50 kilo
tohumundan Tonlarca tohum üretmeye
başladık sofralarımıza koyduk Çünkü
artık biz tavada buğdayından erişte
kesmeye başlamıştık ekmek pişirmeye
başlamıştık Çünkü kavılca buğdayı bizim
için çok önemli bir buğday çeşidi olduğu
için tekrar günümüze kazandırmış olduk
bu a tepemizde
bir tohum takası yapıyoruz köyümüzde ve
çevre köylerde bazen bir çekirdek tohumu
bazen bir yeşillik soğan veya fasulye
tohumunu birbirimizle paylaşarak
çoğaltmaya çalışıyorum Çünkü bizim
köyümüz soğuk olduğu için yöresel
tohumunu ihtiyacımız var ki o
topraklarda ne yetişecek nasıl yetişecek
diye oranın yöresel tohumuna da
ihtiyacımız var bizim
bir tohum temizleme makinemizi çevre
köylerimiz le birlikte paylaşıyoruz
Çünkü paylaşmak demek Türkiye'de tüm
insanlarla paylaşmayı çoğaltmaya
çalışıyoruz çevre çevre köylerimizi
sürecinize kadınlarımıza ve erkek
lerimizi hep beraber üretmeye devam
ediyoruz Bizler
bu burada tohum çeşitliliğimiz var tohum
çeşitliliğimiz detem bahçelerin bazen
Kuzey bölgesinde bazen de Doğu
bölgesinde hangi tohumu yetiştireceğim
bize de bu kendimiz karar veriyoruz
çünkü atalarımızdan kalan bir kültürümüz
var bizlerin köyümüzün eski ismi zavut
zavat Rusya'da fabrika mandıra üretici
demek bizim atalarımızın elde etmiş
olduğu bir hayvan ırkımız var İsmi zavut
savat ırkı hem klavye peynirine uygun
sütü var soğuğa dayanıklı et verimi
yüksek olan bir ırkımız dır bizim için
çok kıymetli olduğu için de hayvan
ırkımız da koruma altında olan bir
ırkımız var
Hı hı tıbbi bitkiler uzman hekimlerden
öğrendik ama sahada hocalarımızla
birlikte çalıştık Çünkü bir bitkinin
çiçekte mi yaprakta mı nasıl
toplanacağını öğrendi ki insan sağlığına
zarar vermeyelim bitki Güneşte mi ya da
hangi ayda hangi bitki öğren toplanması
gerektiğini de gelen uzman hekimlerden
eğitim alarak öğrendik
bu eğitimler mi sırasında bitkilerin
güneşte değil gölgede kurutulması
gerektiğini öğrenen Çünkü güneş
ışığından etkilenen toplanmış bitkiler
içindeki etkinlik kaybeder diye bv1 yıl
geçmiş bitkiler hiçbir zaman sofralarda
ve çay olarak tüketilmemesi gerektiğini
koruyacağım Aslı kullanılması
gerektiğini öğrendik gelen uzman
hekimlerden eğitimler aldığımız
sıralarda kremler yaptık yağlar çıkardık
kremleri yanıkları mızda ve yaralarımız
da kullanmaya başladık ki bizim için
önemli olduğunu endemik bitkilerin
yavrularını Çok kıymetli topraklarımızın
çok temiz olduğunu Çünkü bizim
topraklarımıza atalarımızdan kalan bir
kültürümüz var Hiçbir zaman kimyasal
gübre girmemiş temiz ve organik
sertifikalı bir köyümüz
bu bitkiler imizin kökleri kaynatarak
ama bitkilere de çay gibi demlenerek
içmemiz gerektiğini öğrendik çünkü
hiçbir bitki Toprak üstü olan bitkiler
kaynatılmaz kaynatıldığında ki zaten
kıymetli olan kısmı bitkilerdeki yağ
oranıdır kaynatıldığında yağ oranı Uçar
içerisinde bir umut kalır ve insan
sağlığına şifa olmaz bunun içinde
bitkilerin çiçek kısmı demlenmeli ve kök
kısmı da bir tık kaynatıldıktan sonra 10
dakika demlenerek tüketilmesi
gerektiğini öğrendik gelen Uzmanlar da
ama biz Türk kadınları olarak yöresel
yemekler yöresel kahvaltılar
hazırlıyoruz burada yöresel
yemeklerimizi hazırladık ve ikramlara
sunduk Ama niye biliyor musunuz bizim
bir hedefimiz var bizim hedefimiz
kırsaldaki kadının toplumda yer alması
Aile içerisinde söz hakkı olsun istedik
eşinin arkasında önünde değil yanında
yer alsın istedik ve gelecek
nesillerimize sizler gibi genç nesillere
sağlıklı bir yaşam bırakalım dedik onun
için de biz kadınlarımızı
güçlendirebilir Mac için yöresel
yemekler hazırlıyoruz yöresel
kahvaltılar hazırlıyoruz kadının
bütçesine para girsin ki kadın Kendi
Ayakları üzerinde durabilirsin Aile
içerisinde söz hakkı olsun parası olsun
ki çocuğuna da bir lira harçlık
verebilirsin Biz köy kadınlar için
önemli olduğunu gördüm teşekkürler
ama biz kaşar peyniri de yapıyoruz 32
tür peynir imiz var kaşar peyniri miz
bizim için çok önemli çünkü kaşar
peynirinin Kübizm öğrenmemizin bir
nedeni var Mustafa Kemal Atatürk atamız
filippelli Fehmi Bey Sınıf arkadaşını
Kars'a göndermiş demiş ki Kars'ta çok
güzel hayvancılık süt var Sen git onlara
kaşkaval üretilmiş Biz filippelli Fehmi
Bey tarafından kaşkaval öğrenmiş iz
kaşkaval günümüze gelene kadar isim
değiştirip kaşar olmuş Onun için
Ata'mıza bir minnet borcumuz var ki biz
kaşarı öğrenmiş İzzet sofralarımıza
koymuşuz Çünkü progratik bakterisi çok
olan sofralarımızda Şifa olan bir
peynirdir yine kaşar peyniri Biz de
O 30 tür peynir yapıyoruz her ki her bir
peynirin aşaması farklıdır Mevsimi
farklıdır Çünkü her peynir her ay da
yapılmaz bir çeçil peyniri dokuzuncu
ayda yapıldığı gibi gravyer peyniri de
sadece mayıs haziran ve Temmuz ayında
yapılır ki Şifa olsun gravyer peynirinin
yapım aşaması zordur ama şifalı bir
peynir olduğu için de önemli bir
peynirdir hayvanların Merada otlaması
gerekiyor ki o Binbir Çeşit çiçek
peynirimizi içerisine girsin şifa olsun
klavye yapımında Ustalar çok önemlidir
Biz Kadınlar olarak sadece sağımında
bulunur güç isteye ve emek isteyen bir
peynirdir en küçük klavye 60 kilodur en
büyük klavyede 120 kilodur O yüzden
bizim erkeklerle beraber çalışmamız Omuz
Omuza çalışmamız gerekiyor ki
üretimimizi devam
iyi bilelim
11'e kozawos hazırladık appo Davut
Türkiye'de ilk dünyada ikinci peynir
Müzesi'ni kurduk Çünkü peynir müzemizi
de hedefe var peynir müzemizi nin hedefi
32 tür peynirimizi gelecek nesillerimiz
aktarabilmek eğer biz müzemizi kurmazsak
ve bu sürdürülebilirliği sağlaması Belki
de ileriki dönemde biz bu 32 tür
peynirimizi kaybedecek tik Oyüzden Eko
peynir Müzesi'ni kurduk ama bizim müzem
izin bir hikayesi var de video serisi
simli İsviçreli işadamı Gürcistan'da
klavye yapıyormuş Gürcistan'ın
İsviçre'ye gitmek için yola çıkmış o
zaman trenler atlarla bizim köyümüzde
dinlenmesi için bir Kışla varmış gece
kışlada konaklamış sabah olduğunda
doğanın çok güzel olduğunu ve bizim
köyümüzde klavye yapılabileceğine karar
vermiş bizim köyümüzde yaşayanlar
huzurla Ruslar ve malakanlar onları
bulmuş demiş siz yerleşik düzene getirin
Ben de o
bu izin alayım burada klavyeye yapayım
demiş oblast şimdiki Valilik makamı 1901
yılına kadar binayı bitirmiş ve imalata
başlamış 1917 yılında savaştan dolayı
gitmek zorunda kalmış savaştan dolayı
gidince iki yıl köyümüz boş kalmış 1920
yılında Gürcistan'dan bizim
Akrabalarımız göç etmişler ve klavye
süreci Türkiye'de ilk bizim Atalarımız
tarafından başlamış ve doğum yeri
klavyenin bizim köyümüzdür vede video
Serden kalmış bir kültürdür ama biz ne
de video serisine filippelli Fehmi Bey
gerçekleştirmiş olduğu yöresel ve onları
göstermiş olduğu hiçbir zaman üretimi
değiştirmedik aynı üretimde aynı K N L
XL devam ettiriyoruz xise müzemizi Köy
halkı olarak kendimiz anlatıyoruz ki
birebir gelen misafirlerimizle kendimiz
hazırlayalım kendimiz karşılayalım ve
müze misin tarihini kendimizi
bu köy kadınları ve erkekleri olarak
gelen insanlar oradaki tarihi peyniri
yapımını bitkileri nelere yaradığını ve
köyümüzün yaşantısını öğrenerek günümüze
güzellik katıyorlar
iyi bir takım şenliği hazırladık
kartımızın güzel tatlarını insanlarla
paylaşmak istedik gelen insanlarımız
köyümüzde bizimle birlikte bizim Tadım
şenliğimize katıldılar ve dünyaya kendi
ürünümüzü tanıtmaya çalıştık
ama biz geneleksel üretimi devam
ettiriyoruz küçük atölyelerden birisi de
bizim biz eşlerimizle beraber
çalışıyoruz hem hayvancılıkta hem tıbbi
bitkiler de hem peynircilikte ki gelecek
nesillerimize örnek olalım hem de
üretimimizi devam ettirebilirim diye
bu gençlerimize kapıları açmak istedik
ne yapabiliriz dedi gelen insanlarla
buluşturalım ama başka bir etkinlik
başlatalım dedik köyümüzde beş kilometre
yürüyüş parkurları hazırladık bisiklet
parkurları hazırladık çadır kampları
kurmaya başladık oyunlarımızla
gençlerimizi ve çocuklarımızı
buluşturmaya çalıştık etkinlikler
yapmaya çalıştık git Çünkü köyümüzdeki
küçük çocuklarda bu etkinliklere
katılsın ve bunlar da bu yapmış
olduğumuz işlerin farkındalığını
görsünler Eğer çadır kampları başına
gençlerimizi yerleştirdik çocuklarımızı
yerleştirdik Çünkü burada gençlerimizin
o işi devralacak için bu süreci onların
devam ettirmesini ve bu etkinliklerden
Onlarda faydalansın ve gelen insanlarla
birebir buluşa bilsin diye at turları
yaptırıyoruz ama
ama biz hayvanlarımızı daha çok severek
insanların kucağı ile kullanılacak laş
Truck Belki de çoğu zaman insanlarımızı
da hayvanlarımızın nasıl bir ırk
oldukları da gösteriyoruz yürüyüş
parklarımız da yürüyüş lerimizi
yaptığımız zamanda çoğunlukta çevre
köyleri de katıyoruz çevre
köylerimizdeki kadınlarımız da bu süreç
içerisinde olsun yedi proje köyümüz var
ama başka köydeki kadınlarımızı da bu
yürüyüş parklarında veya başka köylerden
geçerek de bu etkinliklerin içerisine
almaya çalışıyoruz Çünkü her kadın kendi
ailesini ayaklarının üzerinde tutmak
zorundadır sağlıklı yaşatmak zorundadır
ki önce kendi ailemi sağlıklı yaşatalım
sonra da çevremize faydalı olan
evlerimizi Pansiyon usulü veriyoruz
gelen insanlar evlerimizde kalıyor Ama
bazen de biz onlara misafir gidiyoruz
onların
bu kesiyoruz evlerimizde Çünkü onlar
artık ev sahibi kızı 15 dakikadan sonra
bizim ev sahibimiz oluyor bir dostluk
oluyor gelen insanlarla bu at hepimiz
soğuk iklimli bir Köyü Karı da güzel
yazı da güzel bir köy O yüzden karımızı
da seviyoruz köyümüzü de seviyoruz ve
biz o köyde yaşamaya devam etmek
istiyoruz Onun için elimizden geldiğince
tüm köyümüzün sağlıklı başarılı ve
tekrar köyümüzün canlanmasını istedik ve
köyümüze tekrar göç edip gidenlerin geri
göç edip geldiğini tekrar köyümüzün
canlandığını ve tekrar köyümüz gel
evlerine bıraktı gittikleri için tekrar
tadilat yaptırdılar geri güç kazanmış
olduk biz yapmış olduğumuz ve
etkinlikler sayesinde
ama Bizler ilk önce Tabii ki çok zor
durumda başlamıştık Ama şu yine hiç o
aracımız dinledi ama hayat devam ediyor
diye bazen düğünlerimizde bazen
şenliklerimiz de bizim İmece usulü
çalışıyoruz köy kadınlar olarak hiçbir
zaman imecik Sütümüzü bırakmadı birebir
kendimize işimize eşimizle İmece usulü
devam ettiriyoruz her zaman üretmeye
devam ediyoruz biz üreten bir köy üssü
üreten köy olduğumuz için de Diyoruz ki
üretmeyen toplum yok olmaya mahkumdur
diye düşünüyoruz köyümüze
o Lütfen sağlıklı üretelim sağlıklı
devam edelim ki hayatımız yaşantımız
güzel olsun örnek olalım ve gençlerimize
ve geleceğimize örnek olalım ki doğru
beslenelim doğru Hayatımıza devam edelim
Çünkü beslenmek ile duymanın arasındaki
farkı Biz aldığımız eğitimlerde gördük
Doymak ayrı şey beslenmek ayrı şey onun
için doğru gıda üretelim ki doğru
beslenelim diye düşünen bir köy
kadınlarıyız beni dinlediğiniz için çok
çok teşekkür ederim sağ olun var olun